my presentation will be about thirty
minutes and I'll talk about a project
so a little more practical home
compared to the presences you have seen
till now
I'm a nostalgia interface
of google in france and I'm in fact
using all these various
technologies to make a project
applicable in the real world and is
practically a quality of analytics on
google plus you might think the profit
in the real world up to a certain point though
actually google plus a tool
very useful at the company level as
internal social network of companies
so this project is thought more than
another for a business environment
this does not remove all the technologies
which shows the pieces of code which is that
I will show you they are useful in any
application also consumer the application la
presentation you see a little small e
torn up the code will be difficult to
read then it is written there 2r l ve lo
I rewrite here in case anyone wants
look at the code you want to go to
this wars between xv of gm
ok perfect then first of all what it is
the project the project practically
the idea is to start from what you
see on google plus then the feed
google plus news news
all posts that are shared e
turn it into an application
interactive that can show the
report of what happens on the domain
then summary statistics
how many places are the contents
main of these posts what is the
type of sharing that is done the most
often and in parallel also a system
advanced research because the increase on
google plus there are no systems for
search specifically for example
all posts published on such a day
those with containing this string
of words for example then create
some more business tools a little
more professional to manage a domain
google plus what i'll show you
it will quickly be divided into six parts
these parts start from the raw data of
google plus which is what got me
wounded by the pious and up to
an interactive interface that is
developed with aguilar js and allows
show real time
these data then phase 1 take i
given the rai the chrono job for
synchronize your pockets in the background
phase 2 save them with the history of
that apparatus bastian phase iii can
look for this data in a very way
flexible with the greenhouse cpi phase 4
process these data and these are
let's say non-special technologies of
google at the park but they are techniques
generic that apply in environments
with high scalability you have 5 present
this data then with ip airest per
example google cloud end point and phase
6 last stage also the direction if the
google cars to create an interface
interactive
all this is done with google
app engine and python then code field
they will be in python then surely
many of you will think but this one
what wise to do it I don't see why I have to
learn me 400 new technologies for
being able to do something I can
very well done with other tools
the advantages have been explained already
widely today but fundamentally i
of the summaries in three points which are the
first is a unique single code
deploy and infinite scalability if they come
maintained certain rules of development on
second is a cohesive tool suite
cohesive and complete to develop everything
necessary
I in this service use hundred
percent technology on the platform
google gives data origin up to
html javascript and third presentations
point because objectively after three
months four months I work on this
project is fun is a set of
technologies that can also render
nice to work
so let's start from the initial phase
google and ip to Bolivians are the piae
rest
as you have seen before and the thing
positive is that there is a quality
vast are the etnai 176 186
something like that and they are practically
all the same as format means that
if you want learned to use a stack of
google for example youtube then
use that of google plus think
that of the principal or the weather
predictions any p rai will be more or
less the same thing to use indeed
exactly the same thing because the
client is just the same so a
excellent investment
you will have only one client you will not have to
install nothing because it is integrated into
app engine and you don't even have to
update nothing because it does
part of the platform this is a
complete code except for
authentication match to make
calls on google plus and pia e
so what we need to do is
import the most simply from epia
import bild these generic any p
igoogle works with this line of
code create our pious jack
google plus
then the plus plus one version
domaines after which we can already
start the next line of code a
make requests and get answers
very quiet python objects
what can we poor's that we can use
in our code, therefore, just like
I said we have hundreds of bees a
arrangement the two advantages are that
they are all summarized on the google site
in the console folds that you can see a
I think it is
the plans look for the console plans on ip and
console on google and find it expert
they are all easily probable from the p
ex ploner is this trend here was
explained the really beautiful thing first
of the pi explorer is that it is not a site
static generated on purpose for those more
but it is something dynamic that is me if
I modify these pious and automatically the
flora squares and fits and shows me
all the possibilities of real batteries
time
and that's exactly what you can do
you with google cloud and poems i wanted
make a small demo to show
exactly how these these pm work
to take the demo we take advantage
the interactive console
what you see right now is
practically the development console of
app engine what it means what
showed bastian before was there
app engine deployment console ie
what you see when
the application is loaded
on the google infrastructure really
developed clearly worked in
local so there is a server app engine e
true well server that simulates the environment of
deploy in a very very precise and
allows you to have access to a set of
tools to make tests to do
analysis on your code in
development
then let's see if I have a reach here
hand code
here is when we can do
practically execute writings by
python code that is executed
on the source of the application in this
case the application is simple
python application then us
we execute lines of code in the cases
the app engine environment does not come
to look at that matters to him
what matters is the next part
women we create an ep and google plus e
we can start using it in this
case we are identified with my account
can do an experiment for example
then service is our pious jack
for example we want to see mine
profile
there is everything you see
yes yes yes that's what I said
certainly everything you do in the app
engine not a hundred percent clearly
the same thing, however, a good one
approximation can be simulated in
local
this is a net advantage
for example if you know platforms
like heroku which is a little counterpart on
amazon app engine platform them
they do not have tools to simulate this
the behavior of the
data store of the development environment
moreover it is an advantage to be able to simulate
an almost real environment the local of the
gay
the call to the piai clearly on the yes
of course
yes yes yes no no no complaint remains
remain those of playa te now you
I show directly yes
yes specific specific to app engine is
high no but what is needed is a
any of python to work e
presidio then charmant the most evolved a
my opinion from this point of view e
it works very well I've used to
develop this application
and then there is the environment must the open server
with graphical interface for sx sipra per
python and for java
nothing is needed for the deployment
the local plane and automatically
refresh ato with the bild therefore not not
there is to do deployed while you write see
real time python update
we apologize if this when in fact
ok then let's have a little demo then
any questions even when i finish
this part of speech can be given
also the questions this the profile
google plus you see is information
my information is the google profile
plus is a test domain so I am
enough random information in
actually for example we see the date of
birth 28 October
we can make a request to
raw people resource
if it's not east anymore I want to take one
single person then gas the user id
of the person is my email then luca
story to itself todt com
after which we execute the request
execute we print what we get
in a readable way
let's see if it works perfect on the first one
blow
and here we have a prest resource that is
then became a python object
practically in a line of code
we downloaded my google profile
plus and we can use it directly
so here if we select the field
of gays
we want to see my date of birth
exactly we can do other things
these plans are very flexible for
example we can have access to
activities that is, places are made
on the domain
instead of pippo we will write activities
the syntax is always the same
we can always stay for the users
and my email
we must indicate my activities
then the user clearly warns in
this case no longer exists and this
let us put the first example
indeed we say everything
let's see if it works this time here we are
here therefore a list of the activity a little
unclear what you see here because
there are a lot of fields that really don't
we need a very good function
of the pies which is standard on all
google rest folds is that we can
limit the request to some fields
therefore we can select films and
with a fairly simple syntax
we can say limits the answer to
what contents items object content
what to show me if I'm not mistaken
only the content of the posts I have
done on the domain
exact perfect then but leave
read quite a bit of zoom then
in this way we see the content
the object object with ten content
of the post
all this you see is completely
actually so if I am here
I make a nice post a nice post and
I make my request again
maybe so it was too perfect actually
a nice post so something like a
second after my seat went into
america has spread on the google network
since it was posted on the sony
france between the feet google and I took it back
he downloaded it fairly locally
imprinted
now on I can give
this is quite a talk
complex and if you want later we can
explain who in detail however the
concept that this is feasible only
for business profiles in which and who
holds this authority on this dome
domain of google ax di and bind to
checking the profiles that is not possible
deal with a google domain with a
google plus consumer profile but those
that you have at discount in the company then
a very particular case actually
perfect so this is an example
to show how plans are
easily usable and the same thing
I did here you can do it with any
pia and then youtube prediction
any feet comes to mind of google
the senses work the same way
animated with the part after we are
get up to speed we rightly have
downloaded our information from p
rai after which we want to save in
our app engine back end but not
we want to hire a person for
press the reflex button every
two hours
but do something automatically
for this case we have two features
the chrono jobs that are are fundamental
they left that I already have unique if
you know those are ways to
call a rl every tot time in this
In this case there is two real case
stars wrap vitis is called every
the twenty four awards the drink crucible
call rl which executes a method which
however it does not do sync directly because
if I make a request to one by one
real app engine app like
all rl on web server the limit of
then typically 30 seconds time
this is not enough to make a
sync
then at this point we use the
push closed or back ends as they were
been explained and top precedents to do
in the background
the sync of protected activities from google
plus to our app engine application
this just to make you see that there is
a complete infrastructure behind that
allows you to manage these tusk in
background with timing
constant without having to find others
server other tools is all integrated into the
app engine control panel e
not just if you go to yours
development panel you can see the
present and already present pockets
therefore also directly in the development
without having to deploy it already
use this in development next
so we downloaded all the data from
google plus we download them every few
now after that we must save them and
save in the pastor's data store
as explained by bastian before the back
store is a sql database so it's a bit
a key value store where I have an object
I save him and I can take this back
object through its key and gods
here a little more complex
let's start from a certain very simple ho
lost the google plus person too
will have two properties the name and email is
string type properties
then we create the object
activity is here you see some more
interesting features for example
the well-off activity can contain
property of type string text
defining preset choices
so you know it's nothing like that
it happens from the back end level this
client feature in python then
the python client itself checks
that the value is part of that
list of values ​​supports daytime
supports structured properties
starship property where I can insert a
other model in the father model e
supports links
c property then as you see that there is
a key type property pointing
to the person object now the first thing that
many of you will think from a background
and if that is this it is a foreign key
business in what means I can
make a nice already in itself I join all
person with all activities for each
no person in the sense that the days are
prohibited because the games do not work
large-scale joint ventures are not
something that can scale on platforms
distributed because we don't know if
that lost object will not be found on a
server in north america while the object
activist will find on a server in asia
so you have to change your own
the reasoning approach in this
case and don't even think about how
make data redundant and effective from
a scalability point of view
and this is exactly what I will do
now with some tricks ni qua è
right short piece of code to do
see how to save an object in age
store simply creates the object yes
populate directly with python data
and put point is all saves him
directly on the app store and returns
the key ie the link to the object in the
of age store we can do some research
so yes if you want you can do it
more complex research can be done
searches for string equalities for
differences on the numbers can be
also put the values ​​in order
all these things are always to be done
with caution because when reasoning about
of the equidae of this type we are
setting indexes
that is if we want to do a search
by order or by the fact that
contain strings or less app engine
will create an index to execute this
research therefore are intense it goes to level
computational search pia and then la
right part the part on how
optimize scalability and see it
in 5 minutes
here is an intermezzo on how to search
these data more efficiently
we have seen we put them we want
look for all the grapevine arts that
contain the word
hello we can do as I show
qua activity dot content in that case
for each of these we unload the
content and then in python to see if hello
is a saab string of this content now
we obviously have this thing is not
feasible because it means that every way
and we make the request
we want to download all the contents of
all local activities and search
one thing at a time therefore exists in the
plans to do exactly this thing is
the feet full textures where we have
a very advanced search syntax e
especially super-fast
to do this kind of research always
inside app engine how it works
it is a separate document we cannot
work directly south and between store and
let's create a copy practically
optimized with information
interest to look for the activity and
we put it
in this
in society and in this case in the
company and we can do research
as for example is the cerciello cerca
whatever it contains in some
part or ledger than a little bit
more advanced for example if he history
of the second line with ten colons
in the activities they contain and have it
inside the content and greater public
of a date as you will notice these
research perhaps for someone is already
family because they are similar to those
that you do in gmail or directly in
google search the very powerful thing of
this interface which is practically
usable by a human directly
it's not even complicated code can't
physically writing counts in two places
hello and intuitive enough to be
used directly as a platform of
I give you a very fast example of
this thing here then we will come back later in
prototype I developed that you see
here this is a search therefore if I in
this case actually writes a sentence
in vivo search throughout the domain of
google plus the activities they contain
this sentence and in this case I can do
also search for the gate type issue
we see the october 8th but said nesi
published here is this for example
the activity is published eight
October and I can do this research
without having to have complex interfaces
search but with a simple string
understandable by a human
the indexes are incremental and not
they are generated but are updated
every time a document is inserted
so it is not a regeneration
of the index but is a mental mini 5
this means that there are never gods
moments when research is slower and
it means that the only expensive operation
and to the inclusion in the document, yes
however, if not read-only in practice
there are not many problems of haven alone
consistent yes so if with
inserts a document in point of
infrastructure is not necessarily the case
immediately available 1000 seconds later
however it is only for reading so there is not
are consistency issues up
writing cannot be changed
they can be deleted and replaced
so the problems are very limited a
other interesting function that can
pleasure is that it also supports the
search for remote then think of
combine this for example with
geolocation api ai google is one can
search indexed activity
for example, that they have been published
within 10 kilometers of where I am
I find at this moment has this fair
things available at search level
let's say the available fields
to look for are html text date fields
atom means a string where not
I consider the text as a paragraph but
as an exact example string
the email address does not make sense to search
a part of the email address
maxi look for the exact e-mail address
to have a match numbers and geo and geo
location to insert a document is
very simple you see you select a
index in this case activities
document index todt put the document
very similar to indy b to do the
search this is a bit of code
that does what we've seen before a
python level so it's the piece of
vadis behind the application
that I had shown if you wanted
experiment as before can be done
directly in the console so without
need to switch to python immediately yes
can start playing right here
from full text select the index is one
can directly query for
hauer example and you get journalist
of documents that mark this queer e
now takes a document could arise
the doubt this is not my document
of the detainer what do I do with a
search document is pious if not
may have the original document
the answer is simple in the I document
I must also save the key of
original document so the process is
I do a search with the pious search
I get results
these risottos contain pointers
to my da pastor and then I go to
take data from the age of store
using the keys directly
the delta history is super optimized for
use of the keys so if I go to
do one here already knowing the key
Item
the course is practically non-existent because I am
already exactly to go and get it
the object we do
an example of code on python could
being here are some other features
interesting that can be shown
from society and to arrive at a
implementation that is a bit more like
what you see on the page of
google search which or which matter to be there
plans decides a search string in
this case hour for example I create
the research object a little confused
my example
ok which is an empty search object
after which I define the subject of the
queer based on the search string e
the options I defined that were in
empty in this case I choose an index
I perform the search the search returns to me
an array of objects for each object ai
various fields of which I can see the vaio e
you run this had to keep exact
where to keep the list of
contents of research objects
so here we are not went to call the
said store are directly i
contained by the research object when
you make the summary page
imagine the summary page of
google.com there you don't go to see the truth
object that contains all the
information on that site is a summary
simply to show gods
intermediate results of the research
the last function I have to show you
nice snippet fields practically
when you do a search and look for
a test like hauer in a text by
ten lines or 100 pages because here
can scale weight than the maximum number
of characters to 1024 to 1024 therefore
documents fairly categorize the calculation
clothes large enough to know
where did he go to make the match?
we are of the string what you have found there
this sleep and fils function
allows to highlight the part that
we have sinned therefore we cancel
this part exactly right here starting
we do not print the content directly
but the expression of the sleeper field is
an html
it can seem very confusing to see oneself this way
but if we carry it in a viewer
of html like for example gesfid or
we get this representation then
you can't see well from there practically
we automatically make sense to describe
no piece of code
we have query summaries that
do matching on the documents with i
small pieces that do matching and in
bold the words they hunted
all this without having to write code
to generate it and all this integrated
precisely in the app engine without having to
import install anything external
back to the presentation
ok so the part of mice is finished
having a quick recap we have
downloaded google plus information
we saved it and made it
searchable via search and search
this is our task to achieve
aggregated data aggregated data into
In this case I gave the example of a number
average of plus one plus one for those who do not
use if fault if the consideration
of the like of facebook i plus one
depend on each activity clearly
and to make an average we have to count
all the plus points that have been made
divide them by the number of activities
clearly all the people that
they use the one in this room
first thing they think ajo do a
select having aggregate function of everything
what is activity and I get
directly my plus one average
there is a way to do this and in
of b that is in the said store yes it is this
very nice very clean very simple
are five lines of code to make one
very trivial thing and you will wonder why
I have to write all crap for
being able to do what in them
those I did with four words
simply because you don't have to do it is
ugly because it is not recommended because not
is the right approach with a said store
not sql
but sorry
then in this case it is this e
a good question, however, you don't win the
will china is an excellent question in the sense
that on app engine you can you can scale
the number of requests I make in the
suk I have to use sliders for
to know where I got to
my request that I cannot know
how many objects or in the age store from
nothing because the doctor is distributed
being designed for efficiency it does not have
functions such as counting
of objects or an off set is one thing
which can be done in itself as in a manner
efficient if they are indexes equip a
offset in app engine there is the function
offset what the backstage does
function set
if you tell him you are part of the number 1000 he goes
in the data store you pass all the first ones
a thousand ignores it and then begins in 1100 that
that's not exactly what we want
because you get there only from 1100 however
on a practical level
we all paid all the thousand
previous so this is one thing
very bad to do because otherwise more than
999 my code
clearly not what works
it would be to do is take a cursor
see where it has arrived if there are any
I still leave and go ahead with the cursor
until he reached the end of age
store
same thing is also done with requests
on the p
so going back to the example is not this
the appropriate method then what is the
appropriate method because there is no one
function to have on these what I said
first because they don't climb
sufficiently and the answer is to count
every time we enter an activity
whenever we save an activity we
we know the number of plus one of
this activity and we know
we can use a counter for
add this number to something there
we keep saved so every time we should
asking the average we should not calculate
this average
we have to read the average the average comes
updated progressively each time
that we save something this is really
a different way of reasoning I have
past the first month and a half
developing this prototype to reason
as I typically reasoned with sql
then I saw that things
they still didn't work well anymore
increased number of users and I understood
that the problem was not app engine but it is
just the approach you use to do
this kind of computations then
works in two parts a little steinbrueck
that is, something that is done after
saving the activity what else not
makes that take a report object
add 1 to the activity number e
add plus number to the number of
plus as such
I had to do it I planned
exact yes exact said so it seems
seems like a burden to the developer
actually it is a weight of
developer is a different approach though
if you think for example I give the example of
youtube thinks the number of likes the
number of youtube video aics
clearly it would be impossible to count them
at the moment when one for a page of
youtube must be saved by some
part is saved at the time
I like a counter
yes yes even in the sequel and it can be done
exactly in them those clearly a
that point loses the gospel
if you do something jihadiste those have little
sense because that point if already right
in this way you might as well go up
something distributed that is therefore
I want to pass them those you are given
other advantages such as the beauty of the
extra sequelae analytical match of
data structure
exactly the slide after actually produces slides
I answer to this also
question
well obviously this code is a
example, however, if one updates
of the activity can see the dif
there was the delta and subtract it from the total
this is a simple example but it works
more or less on all aggregations
right now it also comes to this
point
then they have all been very good questions
are the next two slides practically
so I finish these two slides and then
return the questions this is just the
slide off
ok then then to get result
at this point I am going to take the object
report I do the division and I get the
media questions before access question
competitor reports as you know that in
data store or on average is recommended by
do not do more than one second writing
an object or entity on a slow lens t
group in the sense that as you see in
this slide objects can be
linked together with father relationship
child where the child is connected to
father they are scriptures on
father or son are all
consistent within the group
what it means i can read how much
they want the group but I can write more
or less once a second and reality
it also works 3 4 3 per second however it is
not advised to write too much on
same group a report is an object
single is clearly a group then
safe from means that it fails
a new vein is found again
time then absolutely miss
consistency if it is saved after later
five times while you are doing
but something else is rare because on the
single entities groups usually work from
a single trend a group entity
imagine it as a user an object
never need to be in the interface
mixing something that can be
we say used from different points
in the single 20 t group is something
cohesively
the answer to this problem is second
me very charming and that is if a
counter alone is not enough for
because people can't write to us
quite often we simply do
more counters we do a hundred
counters and with we must add
something a counter we choose one a
case and we add the number of plus one e
in this counter it is random what yes
called harding is simply mean
parallelize tasks that can
reducible through a function of
aggregation in this case of sum
this code I'm not explaining step
per step but the concept is
when they increase activity extract number
random from 1 to 100 top the number of
plus one in that random counter that
I chose and when I want to have the
answer I'm going to read all the
counters are the data and I get them the
overall answer that I can save to
that point on the single report object
where he will have no more problems than
consistency what we have solved here
actually we don't have the underlying the
consistency problem on
competing writings but also the
consistency problem xvi loc
because you think if I make a put
and I have to log a look for
avoid problems of
consistency on the data if I have two ways
to avoid this problem of
consistency except locke and therefore block
slow t group or I do so
don't write too often in this
way by limiting the number of writes
having so many counter
I'm not even locking because
you can calculate the probability of
lose information to something like 1
over a billion to a billion
probability because practically
impossible to overlap two
requests
this is what on a practical level
works as an example on youtube on lay people
it works like this and then they are gods
tasks that go in the background once
per month to check if maybe there is
was some mistake however at the level
practical it works this way on the
good faith as someone said before
clearly all these things can be done
do even perfectly with glasses or
aduc therefore mapreduce and is the example
perfect but clearly less efficient
but more flexible then the part
the top of my top ended the
part on how to take the data
process them three final minutes
simply to show you a little
result of all this part we have
having taken the data we have saved them returned
look for biles made interesting by the level
then aggregated with statistics
even if only the average of plus ones
at this point we want to share
this data with the world with sites
wind with websites with
applications then we create in the p
I will not dwell on this part because
you have already seen the squares you can do
as it seems to you with and framework and in
php in
python as an example django web app 2
or with google cloud endpoints la
simple answer for google clown
points
you have all the advantages that you can use a
ep to the google so all that
that we've done before
then you can do it with your e pia
and that you have created turns up
google infrastructure then scale
clearly much better than a catch of
django and has a lot of advantages like
also present the xplorer la folds
generated documentation and clients
automatically generated for java python
javascript final interface part
quick survey how many of you know
also lord js none your part 0 give
already something even jazz is a project
quite innovative by google for
create graphical interfaces in
javascript to create sites in
javascript that I am completely
separated from the back end this
what does it mean that you can work in
two separate teams a team generates her
pira and a team writes its interface
of aguilar js and consumes this ep a per
then generate a dynamic interface
the plans speak with the control of ang
lee j es
the young jazz control updates the
data and this data update of
consequently the interface what it is
the end result is this you have seen
first a site while where if i change
an automatic data interface yes
instantly updates and allows me to
do very complex things without ever
going to mix interface then
view controller or data these are
some reports that he generated with third parties
some statistics all these facts
also from the gs if you have doubts about
interested in this part is the site
of andria gesche very interesting and
very well done and yes this particular
we can skip it and say that the
presentation is over